the Joe Rogan experience yeah they got
sick a lug and [ __ ] around or something
I don't know what it was but uh did you
ever see Lenny with Dustin Hoffman yeah
it's [ __ ] great in that I mean he
really came off like a comic you at
least seemed like he was Lenny Bruce now
he's an incredible incredible acting I
actually went down a rabbit hole looking
up a bunch of [ __ ] about him and I know
it wasn't that I don't even hind went
down this rabbit hole but things he's
[ __ ] talk about like before 9/11 like
what you could do and then still walk
around a free man like 18 months later
it was crazy like these people on the
Upper East Side I don't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing this really
radicalized time like the 60s early 70s
um where around that time these people
were making a bomb what yeah and like
these rich kids are some [ __ ] because it
was like a two in a townhouse on the
Upper East Side and Dustin Hoffman had
one on that block close enough to it and
you know these [ __ ] idiots blew
themselves up blew the [ __ ] building
up and [ __ ] with his townhouse and
there's a picture of him if you can find
it is he grabbed some piece of expensive
art that he had bought got it out of his
house and it's a picture a young Dustin
Hoffman walking up the street yeah this
poor guy like had the balls to go after
a dream you know you think it's hard
making this a comic I don't even know
how the [ __ ] you made it as an actor now
forget about then yeah look at it blew
up their whole [ __ ] thing and he's
like I made it I'm on the Upper East
Side everything's great and then these
[ __ ] the building's missing yes so he
owns something close enough to that yeah
Jesus Christ it's crazy it's like all
the building to the building to the left
fine building to the rise fine and that
buildings obliterated yeah I'm sure that
there was some damage there's other ones
so it's crazy how the one in the middle
just missing no but if you look it up
like that the the jail time that they
got the wall I mean you know obviously
the person who was down there the people
down there died I think but then there
was they figured out who was in cahoots
with them but also their parents owned a
townhouse on the Upper East Side
so they present Jimmy spent a little you
know distant your honor you know you
know they go to the same [ __ ] party
you get away with [ __ ] before the
internet they passed around some cash
do you ever see a document shake who
shut [ __ ] Andy Warhol barely did any
[ __ ] time and then years later how he
died I always thought he died on a deep
drugged himself for just doing drugs a
party but I think it was complications
from the bullet wound yeah when you when
you get like shot like I also think oh
yeah Morgan damage well when you get
shot in the gut - that's like [ __ ]
worse because all that [ __ ] that breaks
down your food seeps in like the
infections and the dish oh yeah it's
horrific
what not show him for I I don't know I
don't know I'm not saying he I'm not
saying anybody was a great [ __ ]
person here but that's never a solution
but the jail time that that person got
was ridiculously short and then he's got
to live the rest of his life dealing
with the fallout of what that person did
to him and then also knowing that that
crazy chick is out there
well isn't a guy who shot Reagan out now
no I think they were gonna let him out
and he was like no guys no you don't
wanna do I think he said that I thought
they let him out my memories in the
graves I'm probably combining all three
of these stories and it's actually about
he's out quick-quick he says he's
released so what's his name again John
Hinckley Hinckley yeah you should look
up everything I say actually bill it's
completely the other direction do you
ever watch a documentary on the
Weathermen you remember the weatherman
no with the weatherman we're a radical
terrorist group from the 60s
I thought was like some Ron Burgundy
[ __ ] okay 6007 that's what that
Greenwich bombing has something to do
with that there's like a group called
like the SDS the students of Democratic
Society which was an offshoot of the
whether meant I'm gonna just look into
their Wikipedia this where they
radicalize rich white kids maybe well
one of them's one of the guys who was
one of the Weathermen went on to become
a professor at a university in Chicago
and that was one of the things that they
were talking about when Obama was
running for president he's friends with
a terrorist because he knew this guy
from his from his university days
because wasn't that like the idea in
Fight Club that the Project Mayhem
something like that you're talking about
that's the same sort of idea or they
just wanted to [ __ ] up all sorts of
different things in society and not
troll people by bomb [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about yes we should ask Chuck
when he was in here mm-hmm but the
weatherman anyway the documentary is
crazy they were they wanted to take down
society and they wanted to take down the
government so they were doing acid and
having orgies and she was placing
blowing things up and there was no like
so then we can rebuild it it was just
like rock it up
I mean I think there's a lot of
anarchists a lot of people in the their
youth where they want to just tear the
whole [ __ ] thing down you know I was
having a conversation with my wife about
this really interesting just the other
day we're out at dinner and she was like
when she was young she had a rough
childhood and she was hoping that
society would fall apart cuz her life
was a mess and other people's lives were
great and she had this thing in her head
like oh she hopes society crumbled
because then everything would be [ __ ]
all over the world no one would be okay
because her life wasn't okay I'm like
that's really interesting yeah really
interesting because her insight the way
she was talking about it was like
because she was remembering that very
specifically when she was young you know
chaotic that's why that Tarantino movie
so so like funny to me I loved it I
don't think they ever say hippie without
saying [ __ ] [ __ ] hippies
[Laughter]
[Applause]